Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Robin and we are back with the juggernaut and in this video is the
juggernaut versus the immortal hook. And this is cool, right? This is a really,
really cool story, but here's what we're going to do.
We are going to take this a bit out of order in terms of how the comic was
originally done and kind of restructured things a little bit,
just because there's a bit of back and forth here,
and it's not so much that it can get confusing more so that it could be a little
bit annoying.
What we're going to do here is we're going to kind of pick up with a point where
we kind of jumped back to the past, uh, following Kane,
Marco's escape from limbo. And as he's in this hospital, essentially recovering,
he's met by a telepathic projection of Charles Xavier.
And the idea is that as came, Marco is talking to Charles Xavier, verbally,
Charles Xavier is talking to him telepathically.
So the nurse basically thinks that came up, was talking to him, right. You know,
it's one of these funny things where it,
where like the nurse walks in and he's like, you know,
I appreciate you looking on me, Charles. And he's like my name's Billy,
you know? And he's like,
you won't feel too appreciative after you've had our meatloaf,
but the whole idea behind this is that, uh, Cain Marco,
as he's talking to Charles Xavier, he kind of asked the question like,
are you checking in on me to see if I'm healthy enough to travel to your new
country and rejoin the X-Men right? That's the, the, the desire of Cain Marco,
because remember before the events where he was sent to limbo,
he was essentially reforming. And the hope was that he could become a good guy.
And now that he's,
re-emerged become part of Precoa and the response of Charles Xavier,
isn't a rejection based on the idea that Cain Marko has a, toward it,
a sorted history, right? That he's been a bad guy over the years.
It's predicated on the idea that he's not a mutant.
So it was one of these interesting things where Charles Xavier doesn't really
seem to Harbor any animosity or ill will towards Cain, Marco. And indeed,
that kind of makes sense.
Historically speaking Xavier is always trying to find a way to reach Cain Marco,
to try to bring him back because he's family, right? He's he's blood,
or at least not biological blood,
but might as well be given how much history they have together. And so,
because of that, he basically says like, you know,
I believe that you can reform yourself,
but understand Coca-Cola is only for the mutant population.
We cannot allow you in here. Now. It is true that exude your could,
if you chose to.
But the reality of this is it breaks down to the argument of where do you draw
the line? If Charles Xavier can let his brother in Dan,
if anybody out there is related to anybody who are not mutants,
then why can't they let people in?
And that's when you start to run into a situation where you start to develop
animosity.
And that's when you run into people who are looking to basically remove you from
power subjugate, you, and then take over your position.
That's how you lead to the collapse of Kakoa envious eyes, that kind of a thing.
And, and we're, it may initially start out with, you know, like, you know,
Charles,
Xavier's allowing my brother to be here or allowing my sister to be here or
something like that. As most things in this world,
what starts out as appreciation will inevitably turn into expectation.
And that's what it will become. That's what it would end up turning into.
So that's why Xavier kind of draws a line and says, yes, your family, but no,
you can't come here for the same reason that a mutant with no powers or an
unexceptional mutant cannot have their family here. That if they're not mutants,
you cannot be here as well, right? Because at the end of the day,
you are not a mutant. So what we end up is picking up in Budapest,
following this, and Cain,
Marco ends up kind of traveling through these catacombs and of course pays a
journeyman to essentially take him through there,
but starts traveling through these catacombs.
And it's actually kind of interesting, right? Like,
like one of the things that this guy says is the library is 4,000 years old and
that a lot of old gods are kind of drawn on the walls here.
One of the interesting things here is you actually see the [inaudible],
which is drawn here, which is really, really cool.
Those are guys who were unfamiliar with that.
And we might cover this because I don't believe that we ever did,
but the intestines was part of something called the eighth day story, the,
the eighth day storyline and the way this works is kind of part and parcel to
the origin of Cain Marco, right? So the demon entity Ciroc,
which is where Kane Marco gets his powers from,
from the Crimson Jim of Cinderella considered rock was one of eight demon
entities that existed on earth at some point in time.
And the idea was that they were kind of feuding over which one of them was the
most powerful. And so in order to determine which of them was the most powerful,
they ended up creating an artifact of their own.
And the idea was that this artifact would be placed on earth somewhere.
And when the first artifact was picked up,
that it would lead to a kind of drive, right?
Somebody somewhere would be chosen to pick up another artifact and then somebody
would be driven to pick up another artifact.
And so once all eight artifacts were lifted that in turn humanity would be
divided into eight sections into eight equal number,
and they would all go to war against each other.
And then whichever army representing whichever deity ended up coming out on top
would prove that DD was stronger. I won't really spoil how it ends,
but I will say that eight page, other knots,
probably one of the most powerful versions of juggernaut to ever exist short
only really of his triune form. But nonetheless,
one of the reasons why Kane goes down here in these catacombs is because he's
trying to find a way to access to the rack. Now,
being able to access the Crimson dimension can only really happen through one of
a few different ways.
The first is somebody like Dr. Strange or somebody like Iliana Rasputin also
known as magic who can open portals to other dimensions, right?
The most common way to access a set of rack is to be brought there by rack
himself, right. To be chosen as an avatar, to become the new juggernaut,
to be brought there, and then to have that gift bestowed upon you. Right.
And that's what really kind of what happened with Cain Marko.
And that's what he's trying to do here. He's trying to find a new Crimson jet.
He's trying to find a way to access Cinderella to basically go back to his
position as being juggernaut. Right? And so from there,
we kind of switch over to the modern day.
We switched over to what's happening right now. And the idea here is that with,
uh, with diesel, of course,
the girl who who's kind of been working alongside Kane Marco to a degree,
the one that pitched the idea to him, that she's got the whole plan worked out.
The idea is that juggernauts trying to prove that he's a good guy and,
and no one really knows if he's a good guy or a bad guy, right.
She's almost kind of trying to rework his brand to a degree.
And the best way to do that is to basically have them confront the immortal
Hawk. And the reason why is because she's got a friend who is in,
what's called the victims of the whole group, right?
People who have been victimized by the whole in one way or another,
and we'll find out what some of those ways are.
But then it's also things like she can use a damage control,
which normally cleans up after superheroes.
But because of the ones that hired Kane Marco to demolish a building,
and then diesel was caught in that building and almost killed,
she can kind of pull that guilt train, right. And say like, Hey,
you guys need to help me out with this. Help me, help me, you know,
with have came Marco rebrand himself.
Otherwise I'm going to tell everybody everything that you did and that you
almost got me killed. Right?
So damage control of course ends up going along with it. And so from there,
we kind of pick up with, with Kmart Marco facing off against, uh,
against the incredible Hulk, right? The immortal Hulk. And of course,
DeSales live streaming the whole thing.
But the fight between the two is interesting. For the most part,
it is one sided,
but he really is one sided in favor of the immortal Hulk and his,
and it's not as though Fimian the season kind of plays it like then do you think
the immortal Hulk's going to win? Like, Oh really, no.
Do you have to keep reading to find out that's not really what he does for like
right off the bat, the immortal hoax. Like,
I don't know why you came down here while your stupidity brought you here to
fight against me juggernaut, but you can't win. You know, you can't win.
I know you can't win.
And the stupid new armor that you have is not going to do you any good, right?
So like, like literally humbling this guy, right?
And just like thrashing juggernaut and tossing him around. Now,
one thing Fabian to Caesar does not show us here,
which would be pretty intriguing to get a full understanding of how these
characters compare against each other is whether or not the immortal whole can
stop the juggernaut when he starts moving. Now,
this is largely assuming that his power set still the same and we don't know,
right.
Having a new suit of armor indicates a new level of power or a different level
of power. We're not giving a definitive answer here.
We've just kind of seen him in his normal form. But as we know,
the power of the juggernaut is such that once he's moving, he cannot be stopped.
And outside of the version of the incredible Hawk that was powered by the heroes
reborn universe and was imbued with Celesio technology at the hands of
apocalypse, outside of that version of the Hulk, unless you have a tele,
a telekinetic that can lift jet or not in the air,
no one can really physically stop him, right?
Like he just starts moving and he suddenly cannot be stopped.
And so even with world breaker hope, for example,
he had to divert Kane Marco's movement, right?
He had literally just like send him flying in a different direction by using his
momentum against him. Because of that, you know,
what is happening here is DSL realizing that Kane Marco's is getting pummeled
the way that he is.
It's all based on the idea of positioning damage control to essentially use
their gamma radiation siphon. And so as Kane,
Marco is more or less just distracting,
immortal Hulk and getting the crap beat out of him for his efforts. Like, well,
this guy, can't this guy, this guy can't win for losing. Right. It's just, it's,
it's, it's rough. But the whole point is that, uh,
the DSL basically ends up using her,
using her ability to slow momentum in order to slow the immortal Hulk down,
right. To kind of dis-ease him and to slow him down. Now,
the funny thing about this is she makes this comment about how immortal Hulk is
so much stronger than juggernaut.
Now that's an important moment because whenever you see store or whenever you
see like versus videos, right? Or you see like respect, you know,
immortal Hulk threads or something like that on a comic comic vine or Reddit or
wherever it is, this is the kind of thing they reference. Right.
And when people are trying to find some way to kind of power scale,
and usually you find somebody to kind of cook the books,
the idea behind this is they'll look at something like this and sort of skew it
a little bit, but looking at it for what it is,
it is the immortal Hulk is stronger than juggernaut, right?
Like DSL is kind of our intermediary there, right?
She's our litmus test on which one is stronger, you know, like juggernaut or,
or immortal Hawk.
And the fact that the immortal Hawk is so much harder to keep his momentum
contained so much harder to slow him down, as opposed to juggernaut.
We're literally talking about brute strength, right?
The ability for immortal hope to move against the,
the ability of diesel to slow his momentum versus Jeff.
We're not doing the same thing. So, so it's kind of interesting. It's a,
it's a pretty cool little concept, right?
1990s comics were rife with this kind of stuff.
But the idea is that because DSL can't hold them back any longer that she begins
to you kind of lure the immortal hook in, right.
So kind of lower the influence or power has on immortal Hulk to the point to
where damage control can launch their gamma siphon. Right.
And what it does is it basically reduces the power of the immortal Hulk enough
to where juggernaut can beat the crap out of it, right?
The way this fight basically plays out immortal hope is way stronger. Then,
then the new juggernaut, right then Ben came markup. He,
you actually have to deep. How're the incredible, the immortal Hulk.
I would agree in order for Kane Marco to stand a chance to basically knock him
out. Right. And that's what, that's what ends up successfully in being done.
Now transition to, to, to Marion North Carolina, right?
There's this kind of town hall that's going on here.
And the incredible Hulk is being kept in this giant status status unit.
And the idea behind this is that this is kind of an assembly of people who have
a gripe with the immortal Hulk, right? Who have been victimized by the,
over the years by the immortal, right? And this is one of those things where,
as they run these things off, notice the look of Kane, Marco,
he's watching all these guys talk, right?
One guy's like you wrecked our tractors and cost us our crops and other persons
like you destroyed our entire apartment complex. We lost everything.
One other guy is like, my father was so scared of you,
that he had a heart attack and died. Two days later, my dog died.
My car was crushed. The original star Wars action figures were destroyed.
All my pictures of my girl were destroyed.
And it's just this constant runoff of things that have happened that have been
like collateral damage of the immortal Hulk and the entire time the Hawks just
smiling.
But he's smiling at all of this while this whole thing is being streamed by, uh,
by diesel. He's just smiling the entire time.
And the reason why is because once the immortal Hulk basically breaks out and
then Cain Marco goes to respond. It says everybody needs to get out. No, no, no,
no. It's cool. Like there's no need for us to fight anymore.
Like they all had their say, they had their say good for them.
If it makes them feel better, that's cool. I don't really care,
but understand everything that you guys are seeing here could reply to him as
well. Not just me.
I'm not the only rampaging beast who's torn through the United States and laid
waste to all the things that you care about. Right.
I'm not the only person that's done that. He's done that as well.
This guy has done that as well. The result of this is that Cain Marco,
where were immortal, hopelessly contact, shadow base, right.
It kind of his base of operations for more about that.
We could probably cover immortal hope if you guys are interested,
story's a little hit and miss at the moment. It's a little spotty at the moment.
I'm waiting for things to kind of pick back up before I get back into it again,
but he ends up teleporting out. Right. And that's when it came.
Marco's kind of like, yeah. I mean, he's right.
I'm guilty of the exact same things that he's done.
The difference here is that the whole, like before he was immortal,
hokey was just the incredible whole, he was Savage Hawk.
He had the mind of a child.
He was just being attacked by things I couldn't really grasp or understand.
And he would just go on a rampage. Right. He was just a really, really,
really strong kid, but I'm a grown man. I knew what I was doing.
Not only did I know what I was doing, I enjoyed doing it.
And that's kind of the struggle that he's enduring here is that this,
this whole kind of town hall meeting that was designed to confront the immortal
Hawk with all the things that he's done in his past indirectly confronts
juggernaut, right.
Kane Marco has to kind of come to grips with all the things that he's done.
And that's, what's cool about this.
It's one thing to sit down in a place and to know you've done some bad things.
It's another to have people confront you with the bad things that you've done,
right? Because now you're hearing it from other people more so than that,
you see the anger and the, the, the,
the rage on their face because of what you've done.
And you feel that guilt and that shame,
it's easy to kind of cast aside that guilt and chamber things that we've done
right. To say, well, you know what I mean? I did a bad thing. Yeah. It happens.
It's life. Just the way it works. Right. I mean, you know,
what kind of person would I be if I never made mistakes? Right. That's,
it's easy for us to kind of look at ourselves in that way.
But when somebody is telling us, you did this to me, you did that to me,
it creates a kind of guilt and a kind of shame in your mind in terms of how you
perceive yourself. And it makes you feel horrible. It's inescapable. And so,
because of that, what do you end up having is of course,
DSL kind of live streaming, you know, picking back up with a stream again,
because she had ended it, you know, prior to the incredible whole freaking out,
but you end up having juggernaut DeSales who basically land, you know,
back in the back in Manhattan. And they're met by the arrival of a, uh, of a,
a civil servant who basically says like you're being sued. You're like you,
you you're being, you're Guinea, uh, receiving a summons to appear in Manhattan,
civil court, like you're being sued for,
for the bankruptcy of a construction company.
And you're being sued for $25 million.
So I have no idea how the juggernaut is going to pay it,
but welcome to the legal world. Welcome to the world of being a good guy,
juggernaut. It sucks, right?
Like you got to worry about how bills are going to get paid.
You got to worry about all that kind of stuff. When you're a bad guy,
you don't have to worry about those kinds of things when you're a good guy.
You do. So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core. You guys enjoy this video.
Make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.